I thought Zach played his best game one
thing I didn't appreciate what Rodney
Harrison was doing to me bro that's just
not right I truly believe that we are
not one to judge we cannot just keep
saying someone's garbage saying who's
special who's not special to me that's a
fraudulent move you're not the one to
decide who's special who's not special
Ronnie I'm sorry you can't sit here and
say oh you look at the tape and he's
garbage like come on Rodney like you
didn't even do that you can't say that
he's not a good quarterback he's a
starting quarterback in the NFL and
Rodney you can show me you could do it
then you do it if you were so good like
let his traits and everything he do grow
bro Zach is a human being we don't use
our platform to degrade other players
that's just not what we do we use our
platform to uplift
people